FROM THE SUFFERING YOU SEE.
DEATH IS A MYSTERY.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THAT IS HOW WE FEEL.
JOE BIDEN'S ALLIES IN THE MEDIA
DO NOT FEEL THAT W
THE USE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTACK THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS
IMMEDIATELY, AS THEY ALWAYS DO.
THEY HAVE NO RESTRAINT AND NO
SHAME.
WE ARE GRATEFUL NOT TO BE THEM.
SO THAT WAS LAST NIGHT.
TONIGHT IT IS FAIR TO NOTE THE
OBVIOUS: THE INVASION OF UKRAINE
IS A HUMILIATING DEFEAT FOR
JOE BIDEN.
HE'S OUR LEADER.
HE STAKED THIS COUNTRY'S
REPUTATION, BILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
AND THE FULL FORCE OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT ON PREVENTING
VLADIMIR PUTIN FROM INVADING
UKRAINE.
VLADIMIR PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE
ANYWAY.
AND AMERICA IS DIMINISHED BY
THAT.
IT IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
JOE BIDEN HAS DONE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
LESS THAN SIX MONTHS AGO, BIDEN
OVERSAW AN ALMOST INDESCRIBABLY
CHAOTIC WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
HE LEFT AMERICAN CITIZENS
BEHIND.
HE ARMED THE TALIBAN WITH
ADVANCED WEAPONS SYSTEMS ON THE
WAY OUT.
IT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN WORSE.
SO HERE YOU HAVE TWO HISTORIC
FOREIGN POLICY DEBACLES IN UNDER
A YEAR.
IS THERE A PRECEDENT FOR THAT?
WHAT'S THE MESSAGE OF EIGHT?
WELL, WEAKNESS, OBVIOUSLY,
REPUBLICANS OFTEN SAY THAT BUT
AS USUAL DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH.
WEAKNESS?
WELL, NORTH KOREA IS WEAK.
THEY LITERALLY HAVE FAMINES,
PEOPLE STARVE TO DEATH IN
NORTH KOREA.
THAT'S WEAKNESS.
BUT THEY ARE STILL A NATION WE
HAVE TO CONTEND WITH BECAUSE
THEY BITE.
A VENOMOUS SPIDER IS WEAK, YOU
CAN CRUSH IT, BUT YOU ARE STILL
AFRAID OF IT BECAUSE IT BITES.
WE DO NOT BITE.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WE ARE NOT SIMPLY WEAK, THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT UNDER
JOE BIDEN IS RIDICULOUS, IT'S
POMPOUS, IT'S SELF-INVOLVED,
IT'S LONG LONG-WINDED AND
FATUOUS, NOT SO DIFFERENT FROM
THE FADING OLD MAN WHO LEADS IT.
THERE IS NO HIDING IT, THE REST
OF THE WORLD SEES IT CLEARLY
ANSWER TO MANY AMERICANS.
IF WATCHING THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE THIS WEEK MADE YOU FEEL
A LITTLE SICK, THIS IS PROBABLY
WHY.
OF COURSE YOU FELT SORRY FOR THE
UKRAINIANS BEING KILLED, BUT YOU
ALSO SENSE THIS WAS A GENUINE
DISASTER FOR US IN AMERICA, AND
YOU'RE RIGHT, IT IS.
JOE BIDEN IS QUICKLY DRAINING
THE RESERVOIR OF AMERICA'S
CREDIBILITY AND POWER IT HAS
ACCUMULATED OVER CENTURIES OF
WISE DECISION-MAKING, LIKE THE
U.S. TREASURY, THIS IS
NOT JOE BIDEN'S CAPITAL TO
SPEND.
HE IS SQUANDERING SOMETHING THAT
OTHERS MADE.
HOW MUCH IS LEFT AT THIS POINT?
YOU HATE EVEN TO THINK ABOUT IT.
SUNDAY WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT.
SO THE PROBLEM HERE ISN'T
COMPLICATED.
JOE BIDEN BROKE THE OLDEST RULE
OF ALL: DON'T MAKE THREATS YOU
CAN'T BACK UP.
YOU THINK YOU WOULD KNOW THAT IF
HE ACTUALLY SQUARED OFF AGAINST
CORN POP AT THE PUBLIC SWIMMING
POOL IN WILMINGTON 60 YEARS AGO
BUT HE NEVER DID SO HE DOESN'T
KNOW THAT IF YOU SAY SOMETHING
SERIOUS YOU HAD BETTER MEAN IT.
IT IS RECKLESS TO TELL OBVIOUS
LIES.
IF YOU DO THAT, BEFORE LONG --
AND IT HAPPENS VERY QUICKLY, IN
FACT -- PEOPLE FIGURED OUT THAT
YOU CAN BE IGNORED.
YOU'RE NOT A SUPERPOWER, YOU ARE
A JOKE, AND THAT IS WHY YOU
NEVER UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES
SAY ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
>> THE PURPOSE OF THE SANCTIONS
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AND CONTINUES TO
BE DETERRENCE.
BUT LET'S ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
UNIQUE NATURE OF THE SANCTIONS
THAT WE HAVE OUTLINED.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE GREATEST
SANCTIONS, IF NOT THE STRONGEST
THAT WE HAVE EVER ISSUED.
>> THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES THAT
SANCTIONS ARE INTENDED TO DETER.
>> AS TO THE SANCTIONS, THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO IS TO
USE THEM AS A DETERRENT, AS A
MEANS OF DISSUADING RUSSIA FROM
ENGAGING IN FURTHER AGGRESSION.
>> Tucker: IF YOU'VE SAW THE
DATES, YOU NOTICE THOSE CLIPS
ARE FROM RECENTLY, IN SOME CASES
JUST DAYS BEFORE VLADIMIR PUTIN
SHOWED PRECISELY HOW MEANINGLESS
OUR SANCTIONS ACTUALLY WERE.
THE GREATEST SANCTIONS EVER,
SAID KAMALA HARRIS, WEARING HER
STUPID LITTLE MASK ON MONDAY.
SHE IS A BUFFOON.
YOU KNEW THAT.
NOW IT IS OBVIOUS THAT HER
BUFFOONERY IS A REAL PERIL FOR
THE REST OF US.
NO ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE SEEMS
TO UNDERSTAND THIS.
IT'S LIKE THE MOST OBVIOUS
LESSON.
HERE WAS JOE BIDEN FROM TODAY
TELLING YOU THAT ACTUALLY, THESE
SANCTIONS, THE GREATEST, MOST
DETERRENT SANCTIONS EVER, WERE
NEVER INTENDED REALLY TO DETER
ANYTHING.
SORRY IF YOU TOOK US SERIOUSLY
THE FIRST TIME, WE DIDN'T REALLY
MEAN IT.
>> NO ONE EXPECTED THE SANCTIONS
TO PREVENT ANYTHING FROM
HAPPENING.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME, AND WE
HAVE TO SHOW RESOLVE, SO HE
KNOWS WHAT'S COMING, AND SO THE
PEOPLE OF RUSSIA KNOW WHAT HE
HAS BROUGHT ON THEM, THAT IS
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
>> Tucker: WHO GIVES HIM THESE
SCRIPTS?
DO THEY NOT THINK WE HAVE ACCESS
TO YOUTUBE?
OR MAYBE THEY ARE HOPING GOOGLE
WILL SCRUB IT.
BY THE TIME HE HOLDS ANOTHER
PRESS CONFERENCE.
YOU JUST TOLD US ON MONDAY THAT
THE PURPOSE OF THE SANCTIONS WAS
TO DETER THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE, SO AT THE VERY LEAST,
ACKNOWLEDGE THEY DIDN'T WORK AS
INTENDED.
THEY CAN NEVER ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
OH, THE VACCINE PREVENTS
TRANSMISSION AND INFECTION.
JUST TELL THE TRUTH.
PEOPLE WILL UNDERSTAND.
BUT THEY LIE EVERY TIME.
NOW THEY'RE TELLING US PUTIN
KNOWS WHAT'S COMING, WE WILL GET
HIM NEXT TIME.
RIGHT.
NO ONE BELIEVES YOU ANYMORE,
JOE BIDEN.
NO ONE SHOULD BELIEVE YOU.
IT IS VERY HARD TO TAKE ON
SERIOUS PEOPLE SERIOUSLY A
SERIOUS PRESIDENT WHO CARED WHAT
HAVE REASSESSED EVERYTHING
COME AMERICA'S FOREIGN POLICY
AND HOW IT IS ADMINISTERED AFTER
THE AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL LAST
AUGUST THAT WAS A DISASTER.
SO A RESPONSIBLE PERSON WOULD
HAVE ASKED HIMSELF, HOW DO WE
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN?
THAT IS HIGHLY POSSIBLE PEOPLE
THINK.
IT IS HOW LEADERS WHO CARE ABOUT
THEIR COUNTRY THINK.
COURSE, IT'S A BASELINE
REQUIREMENT FOR
LEADERSHIP.
THIS WAS A DISASTER.
HOW DO WE PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN?
THAT IS NOT HARD.
BUT LIFETIME FEDERAL EMPLOYEE
THAT HE IS, JOE BIDEN DID THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT.
HIS FIRST INSTINCT WAS TO
PROTECT THE BUREAUCRACY, NOT THE
COUNTRY, THE BUREAUCRACY.
SO NOT A SINGLE PERSON FROM THE
PENTAGON OR THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WAS FIRED OR EVEN REPRIMANDED.
IN FACT, FAMOUSLY, THE ONLY
PERSON WHO WAS PUNISHED IN THE
END FOR THAT HISTORIC DEBACLE
WAS A MARINE COLONEL WHO
COMPLAINED ABOUT IT.
HE WENT TO JAIL FOR COMPLAINING.
AND YOU WILL SEE THE SAME
RESPONSE THIS TIME.
AFTER THE DISASTROUS INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
THE AMERICAN OFFICIALS WHO SO
PUBLICLY TRASHED THIS COUNTRY'S
CREDIBILITY WILL BE PROMOTED FOR
IT.
THEY ALWAYS ARE.
TAUREAN NEWLAND IS ONE OF THE
GENIUSES BEHIND THE IRAQ WAR
THAT WAS ALMOST 20 YEARS
AGO, DID THAT HURT HER CAREER?
IT SHOULD HAVE ENDED HER CAREER.
IN PLACE, RIGHT THEN, GO DO
SOMETHING USEFUL.
LEARN HOW TO LAY TILE.
BUT IT DIDN'T END HER CAREER, IN
FACT HER CAREER ACCELERATED.
THIS SAME PERSON, TAUREAN
NEWLAND, WENT ON TO HELP LEAD
THE UKRAINE DEBACLE WE ARE
WATCHING NOW.
SHE IS COMPLETELY UNQUALIFIED
FOR THE JOB SHE HAS, WE KNEW
THAT 20 YEARS AGO.
AND YET SHE IS HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
IN WASHINGTON.
SOMEDAY SHE WILL PROBABLY BE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, REMEMBER HER
NAME, TAUREAN NEWLAND.
SHE WILL BE REWARDED FOR HER
FAILING.
MEANWHILE, PEOPLE WHO CRITICIZE
TORIA NULAND OR WHO CARE ABOUT
THIS COUNTRY ENOUGH TO CRITIQUE
JOE BIDEN'S FOREIGN POLICY
DISASTERS FIND THEMSELVES
DENOUNCED IN THE MEDIA AS COME
OF ALL THINGS, TRADERS TO
AMERICA.
EMMONS SPIED ON BY THE NSA.
DO YOU SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
IT IS -- ONLY BUFFOONERY IS
REWARDED.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY JOHN KERRY
IS STILL AROUND.
HERE IS JOHN KERRY TELLING THE
BBC IN PUBLIC ON CAMERA THAT THE
REAL VICTIM OF THIS WAR IS
SOMETHING CALLED THE CLIMATE.
>> MASSIVE EMISSIONS,
CONSEQUENCES TO THE WAR, BUT
EQUALLY IMPORTANTLY, YOU WILL
LOSE PEOPLE'S FOCUS, LOSE,
CERTAINLY, BIG ATTENTION BECAUSE
THEY WILL BE DIVERTED,
AND I THINK IT COULD HAVE A
DAMAGING IMPACT, SO I HOPE IS
IMPROVED AND WILL HELP US TO
STAY ON TRACK WITH RESPECT TO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR THE
CLIMATE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, HE FLEW
PRIVATE TO THAT INTERVIEW,
HOPING NO ONE NOTICED, NOT
CARING IF ANYONE NOTICED.
WHAT IS THE EXPLANATION -- HOW
CAN YOU SAY SOMEONE LIKE THAT?
THAT IS REAL, WE DID NOT MAKE IT
UP, IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE IT BUT
IT IS REAL, IT IS ALL REAL.
WHAT YOU DID A NATIONWIDE SEARCH
FOR THE PEOPLE LEAST CAPABLE OF
LEADING A LARGE NATION THROUGH
COMPLICATED TIMES HE WOULD GET
OUR LEADERSHIP CLASS, YOU GET
JOHN KERRY.
OH, WE FOUND HIM, THE SEARCH IS
OVER COME AT A FORCE AT THE VERY
TOP OF THAT LIST WOULD BE
JOHN KERRY'S FRIEND
HILLARY CLINTON.
SO HERE IS HILLARY CLINTON
REVEALING THE REAL STORY.
SHE IS TELLING YOU THAT THE
ACTUAL ENEMY IN THIS WAR IS NOT
IN RUSSIA OR EASTERN UKRAINE,
IT'S NOT VLADIMIR PUTIN, IT IS
YOU.
THE REAL ENEMY OF THIS COUNTRY
IS ANYONE WHO DARES TO CRITICIZE
THE MISMANAGEMENT OF
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER FRIENDS.
WATCH.
>> I THINK IT'S TIME FOR WHAT'S
LEFT OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT HAS ANY COMMON SENSE, NOT
JUST TO SAY, OKAY, GO HELP
DEFEND UKRAINE AGAINST PUTIN,
BUT TO STAND AGAINST THOSE
PEOPLE AND POLITICS AND
GOVERNMENT AND THE MEDIA AND
ELSEWHERE IN OUR OWN COUNTRY WHO
ARE LITERALLY GIVING AID AND
COMFORT TO AN ENEMY OF FREEDOM
AND DEMOCRACY.
IT CAN'T -- IT CAN'T CONTINUE
BECAUSE IT PLAYS RIGHT INTO THE
AMBITION OF NOT JUST PUTIN, BUT
ALSO PRESIDENT XI OF CHINA, TO
UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY, TO
LITERALLY DIVIDE AND CONQUER THE
WEST WITHOUT EVER INVADING US,
BUT BY SETTING US AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
>> Tucker: YOUR OPINIONS ARE
THE REAL THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
DARE CRITICIZE US, AND WE WILL
DENOUNCE YOU AS A DANGEROUS
TRAITOR.
BECAUSE THAT'S DEMOCRACY.
SO VLADIMIR PUTIN INVADES
UKRAINE, BUT GUESS WHO'S FAULT
IT IS?
IT'S YOUR FAULT.
NOTICED A THEME HERE?
IT'S ALWAYS YOUR FAULT.
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO PUNISH YOU
FOR IT.
HILLARY DID SAY ONE INTERESTING
THING IN THAT CLIP, PROBABLY
INADVERTENTLY.
SHE DIDN'T SAY IT BUT THE
ILLUSION WAS THERE.
RUSSIA AND CHINA ARE NOW ALIGNED
AS A BLOCK AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES, HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS, HE LOOKED
AROUND THE WORLD AND OUR
THINKING, WHO ARE THE BIG POWERS
WITH MEANINGFUL ECONOMIES AND
NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T BE ALIGNED
AGAINST US.
THAT'S JUST THE SIMPLEST KIND OF
MATH.
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T DO ANYTHING
THAT PUSHES OUT ENEMIES INTO A
BLOC BECAUSE THAT THREATENS US.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW THAT'S
HAPPENING OR MAYBE THEY ARE IN
FAVOR OF IT.
GOD KNOWS WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS THINKING.
ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," "THE
UNITED STATES MET WITH CHINA
OVER THREE MONTHS TO PRESENT
INTELLIGENCE SHOWING RUSSIA'S
TROOP BUILDUP NEAR UKRAINE AND
TO URGE BEIJING TO HELP AVERT
WAR.
CHINESE OFFICIALS REBUFFED THE
UNITED STATES AND THEN SHARED
THAT INFORMATION WITH MOSCOW."
YEAH.
SO WE WENT TO CHINA FOR HELP TO
PREVENT PUTIN FROM INVADING
UKRAINE AT THE VERY MOMENT THAT
RUSSIA AND CHINA WERE FORMING A
VERY PUBLIC ALLIANCE AGAINST US.
DID THAT REALLY HAPPEN?
APPARENTLY IT REALLY DID HAPPEN.
HOW LONG CAN THIS GO ON?
AND MAYBE THAT'S WHY BIDEN
DIDN'T MENTION CHINA DURING HIS
PRESS CONFERENCE.
HE GAVE THEM OUR INTELLIGENCE
AND THEY GAVE